All right, welcome back.
We're here for ICPFX camera hardware configuration.
We've got a number of slides to go through
and then we're going to show you the camera
and its various components and elements.
And we'll get started with talking
about the different cameras that we have available
at the NAND stage, the LA R&D stage,
and here at the Latte stage in Culver City.
We normally like to classify cameras
into a couple of different groups.
There are high-end cameras, mid-range cameras,
and then low-end cameras that can work really well
for ICPFX.
At the NAND stage and at the LA R&D stage,
we use the Arri Alexa Mini LF camera.
This is a full-frame camera with a 1.0 crop factor,
so no crop factor at all.
It does implement a rolling shutter,
which is something that we're going to talk about
more in detail today.
And it is a fairly expensive camera,
about $60,000 for the body, and fully decked out.
It can run up into six figures.
So if you're serious, this is definitely the camera
to utilize for your higher-end productions.
For mid-range, we have the Blackmagic Ursa Mini G2,
generation two camera.
This is a super 35 millimeter sensor.
It does have a crop factor of about 1.5.
It's also a rolling shutter camera,
and it's about six grand for the body itself.
This is what we use here at the Latte Lab,
and a couple of other facilities
also have similar cameras to this one.
On the low end, you can deploy things
like the Panasonic BGH1, which I have here on the desk.
This is a Micro Four Thirds camera.
It is really good for broadcast situations
because it does and has genlock capabilities on the back,
BNC ports for SDI output, for timecode, and for genlock.
However, according to the manual,
it does have some issues with genlocking to 24p.
So if you're going to be using the BGH1 or the BS1H,
which is its full-frame counterpart,
you might wanna be in more of a broadcast situation
where you're operating at 2997 or at 60 frames per second.
But it's a great low-cost camera.
It's about $2,000 for the body
and about $1,000 for the lens
and other particular extra devices
that you might wanna include,
like the Video Assist and wireless transmission
or what else.
Now, when you're selecting a camera,
there are some things that are good to have,
and then there's some things you might wanna avoid.
So let's take a look at the list for good to have.
Number one, higher than average resolution
for its sensor class.
Essentially, the higher the resolution that you have
for your camera that you're gonna be using on stage,
probably the better.
Why?
Because it helps with the mitigation of Moir.
It's something that is gonna be really hard
to get rid of.
However, the LED panels only has,
they have a certain amount of resolution
and a certain dot pitch.
And if you can have a camera with a sensor
that's a higher resolution,
that'll help to mitigate that just a little bit.
You should pick and choose cameras
that implement a fast rolling shutter
or even better, a global shutter.
And we're gonna talk about the differences
of those two later on in this class.
But fast rolling shutters are fine
if you're planning on utilizing genlock,
which you're gonna need.
But global shutters will also give you
a much better result.
And we'll talk about why that is in just a bit.
There's cameras with optical low pass filters.
Now this is a way to place a filter
in front of the actual sensor itself.
And it kind of slightly softens the image
just a little bit so that it helps
to reduce aliasing problems and Moir as well.
You wanna make sure your camera
has really low latency SDI outputs.
You know, anything that adds to latency
is going to be something that you're gonna detect
once we get through the entire signal flow
of the ICV effects volume.
So you wanna make sure that the output
from your camera's SDI port is fast.
Next, cameras should have timecode BNC connectors
along with genlock BNC connectors.
There's a way to get around this a little bit,
but having a dedicated BNC port
on the back of your camera is the way to go for sure.
And then I recommend that you utilize manual prime lenses
rather than fly-by-wire lenses
or something that is more electronically managed.
It's only for the benefit of being able
to have more direct control over your lenses.
Now, if you do have a follow focus
or some type of device that's attached to the camera,
that can stand in for that.
But normally we like to say to folks,
use a manual prime lens, it's a better option for you.
Now, what you might wanna avoid on the other hand,
are cameras with limited ISO and low dynamic range.
You're gonna be shooting the LED wall
and you're gonna have a lot of sensitive color science
to have to deal with.
So you wanna make sure you have a camera
that has a high number of options for its ISO
and its light sensitivity
and having a higher amount of dynamic range
and a greater options in there
will also afford you more choices
when shooting on location and at your stage.
Autofocus solutions,
not normally something that we recommend
simply because they can sometimes choose
to autofocus onto the actual wall itself
and then that can become problematic in seeing more.
So again, this is why we say,
let's go ahead and use manual focus lenses instead.
Signal converters, these are devices
that attach to your camera to convert the signal
from either HDMI to SDI or SDI to HDMI, et cetera.
These signal converters are not really desirable
because they will take even the shortest amount of time
to convert that signal,
which will unfortunately add to additional latency.
So try to avoid signal converters if you can.
Next, anamorphic lenses.
Anamorphic lenses are really desirable
by a lot of folks.
However, they can cause some issues
in the ICV effects process.
They are being worked on and being included
in upcoming releases of the engine.
And once that happens,
support for anamorphic lenses will be something
that we won't have to worry about anymore.
Finally, variable aperture lenses.
This is something that you can get for a lens
that will actually adjust its aperture
depending upon the lighting conditions.
And this is something that I would probably suggest
that you avoid simply because depending upon
those lighting conditions, depending upon your focal length,
depending upon your aperture setting,
you don't want this changing depending upon
what you're trying to focus in on.
So try to avoid variable aperture lenses
and stick again with primes.
Okay, now there are a number of different sensors
that you can find in the various cameras
that you're going to be using.
They're all basically based off
of the 35 millimeter film standard.
If we use that as kind of like what our goalpost is,
you can see that there are a number
of different sensor sizes and types.
You have two thirds inch sensor, you have micro four thirds,
you have APS-C, you have super 35 and full frame.
Full frame basically is the same dimensions
and shooting area as what you're afforded by
by a 35 millimeter film.
And it's probably your most optimal choice,
but super 35 is also a good alternative.
Even though it does introduce a little bit
of a crop factor, it's slightly smaller lens size.
If you have a camera that has a rolling shutter,
it should be a little faster then,
which should prevent some of those issues
that might occur with flickering.
But when you're working on a professional stage,
super 35 or full frame are probably the two choices
that I would recommend.
If you are going to be working on more
of an independent based indie production,
the using a micro four thirds or APS-C cameras,
totally a fine choice, especially for broadcast.
Now, when it comes to the various hardware configurations,
you're gonna see that Unreal Engine of course,
has a virtual camera, that virtual camera
and it's a hardware setting configuration
for the camera back should match
the sensor size dimensions of the camera you're using.
So always check this to make sure,
if you don't, you'll have a slight mismatch
and that mismatch will potentially cause you issues
or problems with your field of view.
So double check this and make sure
that the sensor size of your camera
is entered into the Unreal camera film back.
Now, we're gonna talk about building your own camera rig
and looking at some of the pieces of equipment
of a good camera rig.
Well, when talking about building your own camera rig,
we're gonna first take a look at the tripod.
If you look at the tripod,
you wanna have a really nice high quality tripod
that is stabilized preferably with a nice set of wheels
on the bottom so that you can move your camera
throughout your stage.
This particular tripod,
the big advantage is that you do have
various leveling bubbles on the tripod,
to make sure that your camera is level
and it gives you a solid base to work on.
You also wanna make sure that you have
a good video head as well, a fluid video head.
This is basically the,
it'll give you options to make sure
that when you're moving your camera, it's nice and smooth.
You can lock off the various accesses
so that you can lock off pan and or tilt
with these particular locking mechanisms.
Works really well and I'd recommend that
if you spend a little bit more on the tripod,
you'll appreciate it.
Next, we have the camera body itself.
That's this right here.
This is the Ursa Mini G2 camera.
Again, there are a series of connectors here on the side.
You can see that we have SDI out,
we have SDI in and we have reference in
and timecode in.
These are where we're hooking up our connections
from the ICV effects volume.
So we have SDI out of the camera,
which is leading into our Unreal control station
through our Kona field recorder.
We also have SDI out,
which we really don't need that one,
or excuse me, SDI in.
We really don't need SDI in here.
That's actually hooked up incorrectly.
And then we have reference in and timecode in.
So actually, we're gonna go ahead and remove this one.
So you can see that we have genlock
and we also have one for timecode.
When we are working,
this particular camera has only one port for that
and it's labeled as reference in and timecode in.
So you can only have one cable hooked up at a time.
This is not something that's desirable,
but it's not something that will stop you
because this particular camera can still maintain timecode
once you initially feed it timecode once.
It's a process of what we call jamming timecode
and we'll get into that in just a moment.
But once you've jammed timecode into the camera
and it's locked in with your house timecode,
you can then plug in the genlock cable
into this same port
and then you'll be genlocking the camera to the wall
and all the rest of various pieces of equipment,
like your graphics cards and your render machine.
So in this particular case,
we're just gonna go ahead
and we're gonna put in timecode first.
It's really hard to get to see this a little bit.
I'm gonna put this down.
All right.
So when we push and put in timecode first, there we go.
On our field recorder or on our Atomos here,
you'll be able to see that timecode is now synchronized.
This particular clock is an hour ahead.
It's not on daylight savings time at the moment.
But once that's done
and we've got the right time,
we've jammed timecode properly,
we can go ahead and disconnect timecode.
And now we're gonna switch over and plug in genlock.
There we go.
And for genlock, you're gonna see
on the Blackmagic's screen right here,
there's a small little tiny white box right there,
right there next to the timecode that says ref.
That means that it's accepted the genlock signal
and this camera is now genlocking
to the rest of the equipment here
in this particular facility.
All right.
Let's move on.
We're gonna move past to,
we talked about the camera body
and we also have our lens.
So this is the Zeiss Compact Prime III lens.
This is a 25 millimeter lens.
It's about $4,500.
It's a great lens.
And what's interesting about this particular lens
is that it offers the extended data port
up here on the top.
This, here Kevin, come on around to this side.
This extended data port is something
that's going to be utilized a lot in the future.
This basically will give you a lot of information
off this lens, like its aperture setting,
all of this specific data that you might need.
And if you have a follow focus system,
Unreal will actually be able to control this lens
through this port and get information
back into Unreal from it.
So it's something that is a desirable option
for the future, help the future proof.
Okay, continue on to the cage.
So we don't have too much of a dedicated cage.
We do have a number of things that we've added on
to this particular camera.
We've got obviously some good handles
up on the back and on the front.
We've got a cheese plate on the top of the camera,
which allows us to attach our Atomos monitor
and our tracking device.
But sometimes you can have a full cage
that can surround the camera for the addition
of extra pieces of equipment.
That's something that you're going to want to think about
for the future, especially if you plan
to add extra devices to your camera.
I mentioned the tracking system.
This is the 209 mine that we have on top
of this particular camera.
This one has active markers inside of it.
So these are IR markers that are being tracked
by the OptiTrack system here in the Latte stage.
And a number of these tracking mines also include IMUs
in them, which stands for Inertial Measuring Unit.
That's just in case if any of these particular tracking
sensors get obscured, depending upon where the camera
is shooting and it can't be seen by the OptiTrack system,
the IMU system can then provide some camera positional
and rotational data into Unreal
while these sensors are being obscured.
So it's a good thing to have both.
It's not necessary to have both,
but it's a good redundancy.
We'll move on to the follow focus.
This particular camera does not have
a follow focus system on it.
However, with having these rails here on the camera,
you could add one.
And you can see that on your manual prime lenses,
they have all of these teeth on here.
This is where the follow focus would effectively attach to.
And as the camera changes its focus,
you can drive it with the follow focus.
Those teeth are what are moving
the different rings of this camera.
So on this particular lens, you've got one ring for focus
and you have another ring here for aperture.
And your follow focus device,
depending upon how sophisticated it is,
can control both of these or just one of these.
All right, I mentioned the monitor.
On here, we have the Atomos monitor.
This is the Atomos Shogun.
It has a number of great ports on the back,
just to kind of show you.
Here, Kevin, we'll just do that.
You can see that there's a number of ports,
SDI ports on the back for multiple ways
to get video data into this monitor.
It also has HDMI ports in and out.
And what's also really cool
with these particular Shogun monitors
or any of the Atomos monitors
is that you have the ability to offer recording.
And you can see that there's a cartridge
that's been slid into this particular device.
This houses a four terabyte drive,
an SSD drive that you can just plug in.
And so everything that's coming out of your camera
can actually be recorded with this monitor as well.
Good way to help back things up.
And we'll talk about batteries.
In this case, this particular camera
does have a battery on it.
It is here on the side.
You have basically two different types
of battery configurations that you can purchase.
One of them is called gold plate
and another one is called a V plate.
All that refers to is just the type of connector
on the back of the battery itself.
Once you pick one of these particular standards,
I'd recommend that you continue to use them
for all of your devices.
So if you're using gold plates or gold connectors,
keep buying gold connector based equipment,
or if you're using the V plate, use that.
One or the other, typically.
It's always something that when you're deciding
and choosing which particular camera to buy,
my general recommendation and advice is just always opt
for purchasing the best camera that you can afford.
Because at that particular point,
it will serve you for years.
These are great cameras.
They're all designed to last for a long period of time.